okay
uh
playing a
sort of accelerated
elder 64. i feel like i know who this is
bishop c8 probably i have a pretty
pretty active position here
now that you've gone for this um yeah
okay i was hoping you wouldn't see that
but i'm still doing fine
i mean you can probably take the piece
somehow but
i don't think he will
bishop h4s there's g4
okay he wants to take everything
that's fine i feel like he's spending a
little bit too much time doing it but
obviously he's uh fighting excellently
so i'm just gonna give up another pawn
here to consolidate
and with
20 seconds less he should have no chance
now i'm waiting upon back yeah maybe not
but at least i'm weakening his
position quite a bit
okay it's fighting well
king f5 is coming
rook t7
it's good
he's fighting really well he's probably
better now
good position but i
yeah maybe not
but i don't really care
very excited
okay here we go and there's no time
okay so you played really well in
general uh
but obviously way too slowly